one of you showed up with a plan a shot
list maybe even a storyboard and then
quickly had to change course and throw
all that out the window so I always show
up with a plan um always show up with a
a shot list and ideally you know we'll
pre- Scout or will uh yeah do do
everything that I can to not only have a
plan but prevent it um that said
certainly surprises arise and um and so
what I do is I try to just find a
private space to kind of think it
through um and then come back to the
team and have a Clear Vision uh what I
have found is not great is to show that
you are trying to come up with a plan
while around everybody who's looking to
you to have the plan um so for an
example on a film I did uh that Danny
Glover was in called strive we uh uh
went and saw the location and just at
that time of day uh it was not the right
location um and we had just filmed
another sequence that was was a bit of a
different mood we had sort of gone a
little bit more with improv on it and so
I knew that this kind of four-minute
walk and talk which was was going to be
at this other place wouldn't work so I
said hey let's take a little bit of a
longer lunch uh I'm going to go you know
ahead to the location and we'll let you
know when when show up and then I jumped
in the car with my trusted you know
group and we quickly did a location
scout and we found uh we found these
benches in this park and I thought
that's a better location for this this
is much much better and so then we
called and we said hey everybody we have
a a slight change uh we're now shooting
at this park and so the whole you know
Caravan went to the park um we you know
reconstructed the scene there and
and it ended up being my favorite scene
in the entire movie um it just worked
out I mean we had this beautiful kind of
sun setting through the trees and it was
reflected across this other building it
was it was and the actors it was way
more Dynamic that they were on a park
bench and instead of um uh just walking
down a street and and so that was one of
those times where it wasn't so much that
there wasn't a plan but it was let's I
think we can do better with this and
let's let's explore other ideas but
let's first huddle and then come back to
the entire team and say okay now this is
actually what we're doing this was in
New York City yeah in in in New York
City in in Harlem actually oh okay and
so how hard was that to find like an
appropriate Place To Shoot when I don't
know how busy it was how many people
were around yeah we constructed the film
in such a way that we were all very uh
maneuverable so early on the line
producer was like you know I think we're
going to have this truck and that truck
truck and you know all the also all
these transpo cars and um I was like
guys this is New York we're going to
have parking tickets we're going to have
issues with where to park I mean it's
going to be a nightmare and so we came
up with this plan of basically calling
uh Ubers and so we would just get a like
train of Ubers and everybody would TR
everybody would move and then we would
you know reset up and we had like one
kind of area um uh you know for
equipment and it was also just a
different size of production but um that
allowed for a lot of flexibility and
then uh we both basically were friends
with the local police department so you
know they were very helpful and very
accommodating and a lot of the kind of
pre-work I had also just spent hours
just walking the neighborhood and kind
of seeing what was on different streets
and so there was a lot of pre-work that
allowed me to be able to you know
quickly make an adjustment um and and be
ready for something like that that's
great were they the same Uber drivers
each time different different oh great
hey R your driver yeah yeah exactly
they're like raing cast members yeah my
mom was actually on set and she um
she you know without knowing all of the
sort of context um so yeah my mom was on
set and she would say okay like we I
would tell her like oh we just wrapped a
scene we're going to go to the next
place and she's like all this equipment
all these people I was like yeah yeah
we're we're just going to head there all
these Ubers would show up we jump in she
was like it it was one of the most crazy
things I've seen um but yeah I mean that
also just comes down to
like
uh reasking yourself like well why are
people doing things like this and does
it fit our particular situation and your
question about you know rules of um
normally I mean we did have we did have
some production trucks but we just found
that we didn't need as
many have you ever said no to a project
yeah I say no to projects all the time
um in fact I was just having a
conversation before coming here about um
like the use of social media while also
not encouraging more projects to come in
um I tend to do my own stuff or I tend
to work with writers that I know or I I
like a much more sort of directed
approach um which isn't to say that
people haven't sent me projects and I
haven't you know bought them and made
them um it just uh it just doesn't
happen all the time but the other thing
that's so core in saying yes to any
project is it's such an enormous amount
of time and it really is like adopting a
a a kid you know it's like having a
foster child and so I make that decision
uh
uh yeah very slowly and um uh uh and
just with a lot of of thought of how
much am I am I going to be able to you
know still be as happy uh working on
this project a year down the line as I
am you know at reading the script what's
your advice to other filmmakers who want
to get a lot of projects under their
belt but are there times when someone
should say okay I know I want more
credits and I want to do this work but
this isn't the right match and this
actually could hurt me in the
end it is so important I think as a
filmmaker to trust your gut on things
and say if this doesn't feel right
then uh go different
way uh especially at the beginning and
what I have found is
that for me um having as much control
over a project is also advantageous
because if things go Ary with other
people and you're splitting
decision-making and and creative control
and all these things that can eat up a
years I mean there's so many projects
that have just gotten stalled for that
reason and so the projects that I do you
know I'm I take the lead on those things
and and then and then it's upon me you
know am I going to get this done am I
going to make this project um and and if
things are slow always turning to myself
and saying okay well why are they like
I'm to blame if if things aren't moving
um and uh
yeah I think for people really wanting
to have credits under their belt it it
um they have to they have to know that
that it there's nobody else that's going
to help them it's it's on them um they
can enlist other people to to join in
but it's
ultimately uh it has to be driven and
start with them sure I guess just being
new to something you know we get kind of
hungry for credits or we get hungry for
experience and then just just maybe yeah
how how is it to to maybe say you know
what that might not be a match and that
could actually cost me in the end
because yeah my reputation could be
tarnished you know different things
could happen certainly yeah there's so
many different factors uh I would say
the biggest for me is always a
consideration of time it's just how much
time is that going to eat up and uh and
sort of the opportunity cost of that
what else could I be doing in lie of it
and um and then the other is you know
more as like an artist is it something
that's going to challenge me is it
something that uh I'm going to learn a
ton on am I going to be working with
people that I'm going to learn a ton on
and and sort of open me up to other
networks and and those are I think the
core decisions I mean I've certainly
worked on projects for you know little
to no money for serious amounts of time
but I also knew that by the end I would
know what it was like to make a Studio
Movie um and that for me you know was
extremely valuable um so yeah I think a
lot of different factors at play but um
definitely figuring out for oneself like
what are all the vectors in that
decision- making in order to to proceed
on a project and um and and push your
career
forward